Hi everyone.
Thanks for joining today.
I'm Steven Bazyl, one of the
developer advocates here on
Google Drive, and today I'm
going to take a look at a
fairly new drive app that we
found in the Chrome Web Store
called Ultradox.
This is an app from Florisoft.
If you're familiar with them
they've actually been doing a
lot of apps for Google Apps
users over the past few years.
I've worked with them
in the past.
There's some really great
tools in the Google Apps
Marketplace for domain
administrators and things
around Shared Contacts.
And I was really happy to find
that they did this new
application called Ultradox,
which adds some much needed
features for Google
Apps users--
people who use Google Drive and
want to get things like
mail merge and templating and
batch processing for doc
generation, using Google
Docs and Google Drive.
I want to take a quick look at
their Chrome Web Store entry.
For those who had been looking
for a solution for doing
templating and mail merge in
Google Docs you can take a
look at this.
You can find them in the Google
Drive collection.
Actually it's a pretty
cool app.
If you want to go and look at
the video, and they have a
really great tutorial showing
off all the features.
And if you go take a look at
their application, they have a
whole bunch of really
cool templates to
help you get started.
Everything from interview letter
feedbacks to badges,
some really interesting things
with dynamic maps, being able
to create dynamic documents
based off of, say for example,
contacts, address, or
information that you have in a
spreadsheet.
Lots of cool stuff.
And to be honest, I haven't
actually gone through and
tried all of these yet.
There's a lot of power
here that is a bit
of a learning curve.
But I want to show off the basic
features, and talk a
little bit about some of the
integration things they did.
From a technical perspective,
some good, some interesting
but not supported.
So let's just actually
jump into that.
I created here earlier
a new Ultradoc.
You can actually go and create
these from Google Drive under
the Create menu.
So you can go here and say,
create new Ultradoc.
And this will just give us a
blank project to work with.
And here it's just untitled.
We can rename this.
We'll just make this one
another "GDL demo."
And of course the next thing we
need to do is actually have
a template for our document.
We can use Google [? OS ?], so
we can actually select an
existing template or
create a new one.
And then we can merge that
template with data either from
Google Contacts, from
a spreadsheet--
we can actually even do both.
We can select multiple
contacts, multiple
spreadsheets, and pull data from
different ones in order
to generate that document.
I'm going to start with
a really simple
example using Contacts.
And first I'm just going to
bring up myself as a contact.
You can see here all the
different variables that it
found in Contacts.
These are things that we can
then use in that template.
It's really great to see that
they're using the contacts
integration in addition
to drive.
And let's go create
a new template.
So one of the cool things
they're doing here which is
both cool and slightly unnerving
is iFraming the
Google Docs editor.
This is not something
that is officially
supported, but it does work.
And in this case I really like
what they did in terms of
using the iFraming to display
additional help in Contacts
for how to actually
write templates.
One of the things that would be
very difficult for users if
they just had our editor without
the additional help,
then I would be lost as a user
trying to write a template.
But here now I have this
really handy reference.
I can look through all the
different template variables.
In this case because all I have
is just a contact, those
are the only ones that are
available to me in addition to
some generic ones are
always available.
So let's just write, dear to
dot name dot, full name.
So a really simple example, and
we can even just preview
this really quickly by clicking
Generate Documents.
And here we can see, "Dear
Steven Bazyl, hello." Not too
exciting, but a really useful
thing just to demonstrate the
simplicity and the
power of this.
So I want to actually go back to
this project and bring in a
spreadsheet.
Let's just create a new
spreadsheet, and let's just
say this is task, dismiss that,
and we'll say, clean
house in three hours.
Amount, I'll say $50.
So a really simple
spreadsheet here.
If I go back over to the
Ultradoc, actually as I edited
it, it's actually been polling
for changes to the document
and detected that I added
a few things.
And you can actually see here
one of the challenges with
polling for changes to documents
is it actually
didn't pick up all of the
columns that I've added.
So here I have task
hours and amounts.
Because I waited a few seconds
before adding that third
column, it hasn't yet detected
it, but on its next polling
interview it should show up and
it should show this as a
new variable that's available.
You can go over to our template,
and we should also
start to see these appear here
in our list of variables that
are available.
So again, one of these things
you can do, I can say we'll do
sheet one, task, and I'm
not entirely sure
if this will work.
So one of the things with
Ultradox is they actually do
have different styles of doing
templating depending on the
source of the data.
So for things like contacts,
it's actually really easy to
reference the data.
So basically you have a single
object, you could just pull up
the fields that you
need for that.
For Sheets it does treat the
sheet as a single object
itself, and it does aggregate
the rows together.
So in order to do things
like rows--
well either do formulas, you
have to actually do the proper
template variables
for doing that.
The good thing is they actually
have really good help--
let's actually go
over to that--
on here for how to do all
this with their product.
So we can look at templates.
They talk about how to do
conditionals, how to do loops,
how to format.
We can do aggregates.
All sorts of really
cool things.
And so when you actually start
getting into some of their
advanced features, you can start
to see how you can use
this to do things like, for
example, you're a contractor,
you're doing a job for a
customer, and you're keeping
track of all the different work
items for a particular
jobs in a spreadsheet.
You can now have a nice little
template of a cover letter
that you sent out to your
customers when you invoice
them, and have it nicely
formatted in a doc.
And if you want to do really
advanced formatting, they also
support LibreOffice files, in
addition to Google Docs.
So if the formatting controls
in Google Docs isn't quite
enough for your needs, you
can go use LibreOffice.
And you can even use LibreOffice
online with some
of the applications that we have
in the Chrome Web Store,
such as InstallFree Nexus.
In which case you start to see
that power of having this
ecosystem of applications
where I can start to do
everything I need to do in the
browser, in Chrome, on any
device, whether or not it's
using Google Docs as an editor
or LibreOffice inside
a browser as well.
Really, really cool stuff when
you start to combine all these
apps together.
A couple other things I wanted
to show in here is they
actually do have some other
things you can do in terms of
how these documents
are generated.
So obviously you can save them
back to Google Drive in
different formats.
You can do a PDF, or you can
have that converted back into
a Google Doc format if you just
wanted to share it out to
somebody, specify the
folder and so on.
Of course you can email
these out to people,
send multiple copies.
But another really cool thing
is Google Cloud Print.
I don't have any printers
configured for this particular
account, but this is something
that they support.
When you do the OAuth grant for
that application, it will
ask for permission to access
your printers.
Right now all I have is the kind
of the default saved to
Google Drive one.
But if I had my printer at home
or one of the printers in
the office configured, I can
have it just printed out
directly from the application.
And this is really useful when
you actually start doing
batches of documents.
If you want to do a mail merge
type functionality and select
a bunch of contacts, you can
do that and have them just
print out automatically all
from this web app without
having to deal with your native
printer dialog, or
without even being anywhere
physically
close to having a printer.
So it's a pretty cool app.
And I actually just noticed,
here earlier I was mentioning
about the latency with polling
for the changes, we can
actually see here now that it
did discover the additional
templates in there.
You can actually even see this
too if I just start putting in
a random template variable.
We'll just say [? "foo," ?]
We'll go back and it should,
in probably a minute or so,
this field here where it says
"ready to go" is actually
going to update and warn me that
I have a variable in the
document that isn't really
bound to a value yet.
It's not something coming from
a contact, it's not coming
from the spreadsheet, so
it is something that I
need to fill out.
And it's really good for those
one-off things that you just
need to do that final little bit
of customization for, that
you're not going to be
pulling from one of
these other data sources.
So overall, I'm really just
scratching the surface with
this application, and I do
actually plan on playing
around with it a lot more.
I think it's a very cool
application and something that
a lot of Google Docs users have
been asking for, for this
type of functionality.
And I think they did a pretty
good job at making a pretty
good user experience.
There's a lot of complexity and
there is a learning curve
because it is in a new
templating system.
There's a lot of power you can
do with spreadsheets and
looping and dealing with
multiple contacts doing batch
processing.
So it does take a little bit of
time to really get familiar
with everything that you
can do in there.
But once you get into the
advanced stuff with having
customizable maps and dynamic
image generation, really
awesome features.
And a very welcome addition
to the apps ecosystem
that we have here.
I know they've also made this
application available in the
Google Apps Marketplace for
domain administrators to
install for all their
users as well.
And I know that there are
certainly some technical
challenges that they had to
encounter there in dealing
with multiple marketplaces,
different ways of doing
authentication and
authorization, depending on
whether or not this is a
domain-wide install versus an
individual consumer
coming along.
Something that we may explore
in future GDL sessions, but
they did a pretty
good job there.
The biggest criticisms I have,
and I really can't fault them
too much for these, is the
polling latency is noticeable.
Particularly as a new user for
the application where I want
to do a lot of experimentation,
and going
back and creating and updating
a spreadsheet in the template
and switching back and forth
in order to explore those
features, having that latency of
30 seconds to a minute for
it to detect changes to the
template was a little bit
bothersome.
And that unfortunately is not
something they can easily work
around with at this time.
If they were to increase the
polling frequency, they would
start to run into quota
limitations.
So it's just a balancing
act right now.
Hopefully we'll have a better
solution in the future for
this type of functionality.
And then the other issue is the
iFraming of the editor.
Again, this is not something
that we particularly encourage
or support, but in this case
they did so for good reason,
to overlay the help dialogue
or this little help pane.
Again, this is hopefully
something we'll improve in the
future and give developers more
options for integrating
with their editors.
But in the meantime it's
a pretty good use of an
unsupported feature.
But I would not recommend anyone
do that unless it was
absolutely necessary to do so.
Other than that, a really good
use of combining multiple
Google services with contacts,
spreadsheets,
Google Cloud Print.
And I do know this does
run on App Engine.
You can actually notice the
first time that you use the
application, you will get some
App Engine specific artifacts
around authentication.
And it's one of those things
where it's a trade-off for
developers.
App Engine does have some really
nice features in terms
of integration with
Google accounts.
The downside to using those
features is you do pay a
little bit of a penalty on the
user experience, because of
the separation between the App
Engine login screen and the
OAuth grant.
If you end up with a two-step
approval, which we're not
going to actually show here,
but the first time that you
use this application you do
actually have to do two steps
to authorize the application
fully.
That could have been avoided
by doing a pure OAuth two
based system for both
authenticating and authorizing
user and do it in one step.
But they would have had to write
a little bit more code
in order to manage the users
themselves rather than using
App Engine's built-in
user service.
Yeah, I'm actually really
excited to play with this
application.
I actually have a lot of things
in mind just personally
for how this could be useful.
My family, we send out lots of
stuff around the holidays, and
I could see doing--
as our news around the holidays
grows, and I want to
start doing form letters,
I probably
will be using Ultradox.
Other than that, really good job
to the guys at Florisoft.
And I think that's
it for today.
So try Ultradox if you are
looking for templating in
Google Docs, or mail merge
functionality.
It's a really cool product.
Come back next week, and I don't
know if we have a topic
set, but we do have a few
things in the pipeline.
So hopefully some new features
that we can announce next
week, and if so, I think
they will make for
very interesting sessions.
Thanks, and see you
all next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]